et pour en parler nous sommes avec
l'autre blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir clos
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
pour bien qu'on comprenne pourquoi le
royaume uni at il refusé jusque-là
l'extradition de julian assange
parce que julian assange est tombé sur
un sur une magistrate parfaitement
indépendantes comme le sont généralement
les magistrats en grande bretagne elle a
accueilli est là elle a réfuté tous les
arguments de la défense de au sort de la
saint jean qui
visait à annihiler l'accusation de
l'administration américaine mais pour
autant elle a accueilli un rapport d'un
psychiatre qui jugeait que il serait
probablement dangereux d'extrader julian
assange parce que il était
psychologiquement fragile déprimée
probablement avec des tendances
suicidaires et que son incarcération aux
états unis d
interrogatoire très dur pour l amener à
finalement mettre fin à ses jours et
c'est pourquoi elle avait refusé
l'extradition donc voilà pour le premier
épisode et aujourd'hui c'est l'appel sur
ce même motif est ce qu'il est en état
d'être extradé ou pas c'est là dessus et
les états unis effectivement sont venus
avec des arguments nouveaux que vous
avez expliqué tout à l'heure à l'écran à
savoir que pendant sa longue son nom
confinement à l'ambassade d'équateur et
bien il a eu deux enfants il a une
compagne qui était son avocate et de
l'époque et par conséquent peut-être
n'était-il pas dans un état
psychologique si déprimée que cela alors
est ce que la haute cour de londres
pourrait décider cette fois de répondre
à la demande des états unis alors la
haute cour pourrait en effet
recevoir les arguments invoqués par
l'accusation par l'administration
américaine mais dans le fond le fait
d'avoir une compagne et d'avoir deux
enfants cela n'annule pas les expertises
du psychiatre qui a dit qu'il était au
moment où il a fait l'expertisé
c'est à dire au début de cette année
déprimés avec des tendances suicidaires
donc il est bien possible que la haute
cour décide comme la juge du mois de
janvier qu'il n'est pas en état d'être
extradé il y aura d'autres recours pour
washington le cas échéant oui il y a
d'autres recours il y a évidemment la
cour suprême britannique
si elle accepte de se saisir du sujet
elle n'est pas obligé de l'accepter elle
peut dire que dans le fond le tribunal
qui siège aujourd'hui assiégèrent en
dernier recours et de toute façon après
cela il faudra qu'un signe un pas
extradition il faudra qu'un tribunal
britannique juste sur le fond c'est à
dire quelles sont les fautes commises
assange est est-ce que c'est condamnable
en vertu du droit britannique ou droit
international alors j'ai une assange
absent avait on l'a dit avec être sa
technique et à l'ouverture de l'audience
c'est un symbole très fort en tout cas
c'est pour confirmer ce que dit sa
compagne de son ancien avocat at elle
dit en effet qu'il est dans un état
physique d'épuisement total qui est en
très mauvais état et qu'il ne peut pas
comparaître normalement donc c'est la
confirmation de ses dires et
probablement que des médecins pourront
problème si confirmer ou infirmer pour
le pour que la cour siège est pas de sa
décision en connaissance de cause alors
les enjeux évidemment toile blanche
présents sont éminemment politique on le
rappelle les procédures contre julian
assange ont été lancées sous le mandat
de donald trump presque ça peut changer
le fait qu'il y ait un autre président
américain moi je pense que c'est très
politique pour une raison tout à fait
fondamental c'est que quel état au monde
peut accepter que les secrets d'état
soient divulguées par un journaliste
alors effectivement c'est la liberté de
la presse
versus le secret des alertes beaucoup de
soutien voilà alors on peut
effectivement estimé que les secrets
d'état devraient disparaître à ce moment
là la correspondance des circuits un
étatique changer complètement de nature
celle des ambassadeurs celle les
généraux sur les théâtres d'opérations
change raid nature s'il savait que ceci
doit être portée sur la place publique
des lendemains par conséquent je pense
que la plupart des états à des systèmes
étatiques
souhaite car quelqu'un qu'un système de
communications secrètes demeure sans
qu'il soit exposé à être immédiatement
mis sur la place publique et on peut
être d'un avis contraire et c'est ce
débat qui actuellement a lieu entre en
effet les organisations qui défendent
les droits de l'homme et les états il
n'y a pas beaucoup d'états qui viennent
dire que ils sont prêts à renoncer à des
communications cryptées et à l'existence
de secret d'état sauf si évidemment on
utilise ce secret d'état pour couvrir
des crimes contre l'humanité et c'est un
peu ce que dit aux anges il dit que
l'armée américaine a commis des crimes
en afghanistan en irak et que c'est cela
qui l'a dénoncé au risque de mettre en
danger les gens dont les noms figuraient
dans ses communications qui l'a rendu
public les journaux qu'on utilisait ces
textes disent qu'ils ont soigneusement
épuré c'était qui l'ont enlevé tous les
noms pour éviter que les personnes
soient mises en danger mais évidemment
on ne peut pas exclure que certaines
indications puisse être utilisée pour
mettre des vies en danger merci claude
gans maison d'avoir été avec nous pour
nous apporter votre éclairage